einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu unserer corona sprechstunde welche
wege führen aus der korona krise dass
das thema heute unseres streams und
bevor wir uns darüber mit dem fachmann
unterhalten wollen wir zunächst mal
unseren blick noch ein wenig weiten weg
vom rein medizinischen standpunkt hin
zum großen ganzen denn heute hat der
ethikrat sich zu wort gemeldet und seine
einschätzung der situation abgegeben
und da wurde deutlich dass es aus sicht
dieser experten keineswegs zu früh es
sich über ausstiegs gedanken
ausstiegsszenarien für mehr gedanken zu
machen
im gegenteil dass es sogar sehr wichtig
ist darüber nachzudenken wir hören mal
rein darf deutschland bereits jetzt über
ein ende der kontakt beschränkungen
nachdenken und über die möglichkeit von
lockerungen debattieren
von vielen der entscheidenden
politikerinnen und politikern kommt die
eindeutige aussage üben sie sich in
geduld
der ethikrat hat eine klare position
entwickelt die nach wie vor nach unserer
auffassung bestand hat sie lautet es ist
derzeit noch zu früh für lockerungen
aber es ist nie zu früh für eine
öffentliche diskussion über öffnungs
perspektiven
es stimmt nicht dass man damit den
menschen falsche hoffnungen machen würde
hoffnung hoffnungs bilder brauchen
menschen genau dann wenn sie in einer
katastrophalen situation wie der
jetzigen sind das motiviert zum
durchhalten
das motiviert zum durchhalten so also
der vorsitzende des ethikrats und
darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen unter
anderem darüber mit unserem heutigen
experten mit professor tobias kurth von
der berliner charité einen schönen guten
abend herr kurz sie sind experte auf den
gebieten epidemiologie und bevölkerungs
gesundheit sie haben gerade den ton
gehört herr professor kurt wie lange
müssen wir denn noch warten ja einen
schönen glanz aus berlin
ich stelle der einschätzung des
vorsitzenden des ethikrates hier
vollkommen zu sehr wichtig dass wir
natürlich
sich jetzt anfangen zu diskutieren uns
eben auch hoffnung machen
es ist schwierig zu sagen wann was genau
passieren wird und passieren soll und
wir sehen jetzt natürlich auch von
anderen länder gewisse entwicklungen die
uns vielleicht das gefühl gegeben dass
wir hier etwas etwas getrieben werden
wir müssen auch verstehen dass wir
wegkommen müssen von der betrachtung
einzelner zahlen und bei deren
unterschreiten und man dann sagt okay
und jetzt können wir wieder im prinzip
die lockerungen beginnen uns das normale
leben aufnehmen
es ist ja eine ganze kaskade die richtig
es geht ja nicht nur um eine reduktion
der neuen infektionen sondern es geht
vor allem darum dass das
gesundheitssystem stabilisiert wird dass
die patientinnen und patienten versorgt
werden können übrigens nicht nur die
cola virus infizierten sondern auch
andere erkrankungen dies natürlich
weiterhin gibt wie zb er zu
veranschlagen und krebserkrankungen und
so muss man verschiedene dinge gemeinsam
sehen und gemeinsam beurteilen und das
je nach land mit der entsprechenden
situation in der bevölkerung bezahlen
wird wo man dann zu einer entscheidung
kommen
aber die diskussion darüber die ist ganz
wichtig und es müssen sie auch
verschiedene modelle jetzt diskutiert
werden nicht nur die medizinischen genau
herr professor gut wir sprechen gleich
auch noch über das ausland wie das in
anderen ländern auch gehandhabt wird wir
beziehen aber auch immer unsere
zuschauer bzw auch die user mit ein und
von mats auf youtube erreicht uns die
frage muss man generell menschenleben
und wirtschaftliches wohl gegeneinander
abwägen
in dieser situation ja ich glaube so
darf man nicht denken natürlich ist ein
menschen die ihm sehr viel herz aber die
ökonomischen konsequenzen zu
psychologischen konsequenzen die
sozialen konsequenzen die wir jetzt auch
erleben werden
die sind natürlich auch nicht gerade
förderlich für die gesundheit insofern
müssen wir verschiedene dinge
berücksichtigt werden wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht die die jetzt
unsere hilfe brauchen
die die älteren
oder und abenden wird nämlich vor
erkrankungen ausschließen
wir werden es nur eines gesellschaft
zusammen schaffen uns abwägungen 1 gegen
das andere sind sehr schwierigen helfen
vielleicht jetzt auch nicht weiter wir
schauen gerade nochmal auf die aktuellen
zahlen dass wir da auch noch einmal eine
basis haben für unser weiteres gespräch
das kennt ihr liebe zuschauer mit
sicherheit auch das ist also hier die
seite der johns hopkins universität in
der immer die aktuellen zahlen
aufgeführt werden weltweit 1,3 millionen
infizierte wenn wir uns jetzt
deutschland anschauen dann sehen wir
dass hier die zahl bei 105.000 etwa
liegt im moment und da gucken wir auch
nochmal auf die zahlen was die
todesfälle in verbindung mit 19 angeht
da sind wir bei 1905 immerhin aber auch
bei 36 1081 genesenen es fällt auf dass
im verhältnis zur total zur totalen
anzahl von infizierten die
sterblichkeitsrate in deutschland immer
noch relativ gering ist worauf führen
sie das zurück herr professor kurt also
erst mal sind die infizierten ja nur die
die getestet worden sind und positiv
getestet worden sind wir haben in
deutschland so viele getestet und die
positiv getestet worden sind sind
deutlich jünger und wie in anderen
ländern das heißt das wenn man jetzt
hier eine situation wo vorwiegend die
älteren sterben und dass es dann so
aussieht als ob wir eine bessere
neutralität warte man muss davon
ausgehen dass der bus ja der gleiche ist
egal ob das in deutschland beobachten in
österreich mit usa in italien und
letztendlich denke ich wenn wir die per
altersgruppen vergleichen und die
sterblichkeit in den altersgruppen dass
wir dann ähnliche zahlen sehen lena
kirche fragt uns über youtube ist es
ethisch vertretbar kinder und junge
menschen so stark in ihrem leben
einzuschränken wegen einem virus der sie
nicht mal gefährdet vorausgesetzt sie
haben keine vorerkrankung
ja ich verstehe die diskussion natürlich
es ist klar dass man jetzt in einer sehr
extreme situation ist wohl dieser
einschränkungen fahren muss um das
gesundheitssystem zu stabilisieren wir
haben hier war auch schon vor diskutiert
dass es jetzt wichtig ist entsprechend
auch andere modelle andere konsequenzen
vielleicht in direkte konsequenzen das
sind die ökonomischen konsequenzen die
biologischen konsequenzen und so weiter
mit berücksichtigen
es kann jetzt aber auch nicht sein dass
wir dass wir bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen ob das jetzt die
jugend sind die gesunden sinn die wunde
abend sind herausnehmen und hier gewisse
dinge extra fahrten statt das dafür sind
die als gesellschaft auch nicht im
prinzip bereit und so haben wir uns die
letzten jahrzehnte ja eigentlich auch
nicht entwickelt und da sollten wir
jetzt hier auch tunlichst vermeiden eine
moralisch ethische diskussion zu führen
ob es besondere gruppen gibt die im
prinzip jetzt wieder ein normales leben
führen können wir haben uns für in die
kurven angeguckt sowohl die infizierten
als auch die todesfälle die experten
gehen davon aus dass beide schon auch
stark steigen werden jetzt in den
nächsten wochen trotz der ergriffenen
maßnahmen wie sehen sie denn das
deutsche gesundheitssystem darauf
vorbereitet also man muss sagen dass das
solche gesundheitssystem sehr gut
aufgestellt ist es kommt natürlich aber
trotzdem dass so eine massive pandemie
an an die anti gelsen wenn sie die
regionalen zustände in norditalien sich
angucken in spanien in frankreich und
jetzt vor allem was akut in new york
dann haben sie dort ganz andere
verhältnisse von den möglichkeiten die
uns eben hier noch zurück zur verfügung
stehen
wir versuchen ja diese maßnahmen
durchzuführen um die behandlung der
patientinnen und patienten zu
ermöglichen und dann in zukunft eben das
zu verbessern
wie ist denn aus ihrer sicht die
situation was die anzahl von
intensivbetten angeht aber auch was die
anzahl von schutzausrüstung für das
fachpersonal angeht das sind die themen
die zuletzt stark in der diskussion
waren ja also wir haben natürlich einen
globalen mangel an schutzmaßnahmen die
jetzt sehr wichtig sind das medizinische
personal ich glaube musste auch von
erkranken
aus dem krankenhaus und arztpraxis zur
arztpraxis und region zu region denken
im durchschnitt denke ich haben wir noch
genügend material zur verfügung aber es
ist wichtig dass die materialien die
jetzt eben da sind für die medizinischen
teams zur verfügung gestellt werden
dann gucken wir mal über die deutschen
grenzen hinaus sie haben das ausland
selbst im mehrfach auch schon
angesprochen österreich zum beispiel
hatte angekündigt seine strengen relativ
strenge maßnahmen zumindest teilweise zu
lockern auch aus dänemark und tschechien
haben uns ähnliche nachrichten erreicht
und dann wollen wir doch schauen wie
aktuell überhaupt der stand ist wenn wir
jetzt mal außerhalb von deutschland
gucken ein paar beispiele haben wir
angesprochen michael spindler bringt uns
da auf den aktuellen stand der dinge
nach drei wochen ruhe modus besteht in
österreich jetzt zumindest die aussicht
auf lockerung der beschränkungen
so sollen ab dem 14 april kleinere
geschäfte und baumärkte wieder öffnen
ab anfang mai könnten dann auch andere
läden nachziehen gastronomie und hotels
sollen erst mitte mai wieder öffnen und
etwas überraschend der schulbetrieb soll
wahrscheinlich erst danach wieder
starten
die logik kann ich nachvollziehen
schulen sind nunmal orte wo sehr viele
menschen auf engstem raum zusammen sind
und geschäfte sind besser kontrollierbar
da kann man die kontakte zwischen den
menschen besser regeln insofern kann man
das nachvollziehen
dänemark macht es anders dort sollen ab
15 april zunächst kindergärten und
bestimmte schulen geöffnet werden
auch für diesen weg gibt es gute gründe
das argument für das wieder aktivieren
der schule und der universität ist eben
dass dort menschen sind von denen wir
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit annehmen
dass sie nicht schwer erkranken werden
und das ist vielleicht sogar erwünscht
ist dass in dieser bevölkerungsgruppe
jetzt relativ früh schon die ausbildung
einer immunität entsteht so dass wir
dann im herbst und diese person dann
nicht mehr so kümmern müssen
voraussetzungen für die lockerungen ist
allerdings dass viele andere
einschränkungen weiter strikt befolgt
werden in österreich wird die
verpflichtung zum tragen von
schutzmasken ausgeweitet sie soll nun
nicht nur in supermärkten sondern auch
in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln gelten
die alpenrepublik hatte gut eine woche
früher als deutschland strenge maßnahmen
zur eindämmung des virus eingeführt der
vorsprung macht sich auch in der
statistik bemerkbar so beträgt der
verdopplung zeitraum der positiven
corona fälle inzwischen etwa 25 tage
während er in deutschland erst bei rund
12 tagen legt hat österreich die bessere
strategie das jetzt hier nicht so
vergleichen bewerten wollen wir haben
auch ganz unterschiedliche situationen
wie gesagt der zeitpunkt ist anders es
des landes anders in deutschland zum
beispiel haben wir bilden eine ganz
andere situation als im norden so dass
man da auch in deutschland nicht so ohne
weiteres einheitlich verfahren kann
fakt ist aber dass in deutschland die
sehnsucht nach einem fahrplan zur
normalität groß ist bis zum 19 april ist
mit keinen lockerungen zu rechnen könnte
deutschland danach erste schritte wie
österreich wagen das alles entscheidende
ist doch ob wir in der lage sind das
aufkommen dieser schwer erkrankten
patienten zu bewältigen
wenn also unser gesundheitssystem in der
lage ist damit umzugehen und wenn wir
hinweise haben dass das zu managen ist
dann können wir davon ausgehen dass man
auch wieder lockern kann
die rückkehr zu normalität lässt also
noch auf sich warten aber es gibt
zumindest einen hoffnungsschimmer
wir sprechen weiter er mit professor
tobias kurth von der berliner charité er
ist experte für epidemiologie herr kurth
also wir haben gerade gesehen in einigen
ländern werden die maßnahmen
zurückgefahren zumindest ist das
angekündigt worden wo liegt der
unterschied zu deutschland oder anders
gefragt warum sind wir noch nicht so
weit wie zum beispiel österreich oder
dänemark browser das ist ja mal schon
beitrag gesagt ein direktvergleich ins
natürlich immer schwierig weil die
zahlen auch natürlich schwer verglichen
werden in österreich haben wir eine
situation wo eben die maßnahmen
eingeleitet worden sind es läuft etwas
deutlicher um die eingeleitet worden
sind und vor allem auch eine sehr gute
wie ich finde kommunikation mit der
bevölkerung sehr klare im prinzip ja
nicht an weisungen aber klare
erklärungen warum gewisse dinge
umgesetzt werden müssen
ein parallel ihm auch verschiedene
modelle die die hier auf
präventionsmaßnahmen gegen häusliche
gewalt oder andere dinge angefahren habe
ich denke das müssen wir in deutschland
auch noch erreichen dass wir die
bevölkerung mitnehmen in österreich wie
gesagt die zahlen sind etwas rückläufig
wir werden das in deutschland auch sehen
wie hinten etwas hinterher weil wir
später angefangen haben bzw
infektionswelle auch etwas später uns
erreicht hat und herr professor krauss
hat ja auch schon gesagt es ist wichtig
ist dass das gesundheitssystem jetzt
stabilisiert werden muss und wenn das
erreicht wird dass man hier sieht man
kann hier die patientinnen und patienten
versorgung ich denke dann ist ein guter
zeitpunkt eine weitere schritte zu
diskutieren welches modell überzeugt sie
dann mehr das dänische also wo mit dem
bildungssektor mit den kitas mit den
schulen angefangen wird da wieder zu
lockern oder das österreichische wo es
mehr um die wirtschaft den handel und so
weiter geht wissen sie ich bin jetzt
nicht in der lage verschiedene modelle
im ausland zu diskutieren ich glaube wir
haben in deutschland eine situation wo
jeden tag aufs neue die situation sehr
genau angeschaut wird und eben für den
deutschen raum dann auch entschieden
wird
es müssen wie gesagt in verschiedene
berater mitgedacht werden aber eben auch
jetzt eine diskussion anfangen über die
konsequenzen im kulturellen bereich im
ökonomischen bereich und so weiter
was immer als soziale distanzierung
bezeichnet wird sich ein falsches wort
weil wir müssen jetzt die sozialen
kontakte nach oben fahren es ist eine
physikalische körperliche distanzierung
die wir erreichen müssen hier müssen wir
auch entsprechend besser kommunizieren
also ich würde jetzt kein modell
favorisieren weil sie im prinzip bis
modelle aus eher schwierig nach
deutschland bringen können dann schauen
wir uns doch gerade noch mal die zahlen
an die vielleicht auch ganz wichtig sind
in diesem zusammenhang dafür auch im
beitrag von michael spindler schon an
wenn wir uns das zum beispiel auf der
zdf heute seite ansehen das ist nämlich
die verdopplung zeit der chor mit 19
pandemie 12,2 tage beträgt aktuell der
wert für deutschland wir haben ja einige
andere zahlen auch aus den usa zum
beispiel 6,4
wenn man weiter runter scrollt dann
sieht man auch die entwicklung für
deutschland das war am ersten dritten
war das noch 1,7 und wie gesagt im
moment sind wir bei 12,2 können sie uns
als fachmann nochmal einordnen inwieweit
dieser wert wichtig ist und wie weit er
jetzt in deutschland sagen mal auf einem
guten niveau oder weniger guten niveau
ist sie wert ist wichtig ist aber auch
nur ein herz die fertigungsrate zeit und
7 die geschwindigkeit jeweils eine
infektion über deutschland wollt wenn
sie so wollen
was wir sehen ist dass es eine
verlangsamung liegt das wollten wir
erreichen aber es gibt auch andere
messzahlen sie wichtig sind das ist die
stabilisierung des gesundheitssystems
und andere moderne dich angesprochen
fühlst du eben keine entscheidung
getroffen werden nur aufgrund einer
bestimmten zahl
das leuchtet ein wir fragen natürlich
weiter auch bei unseren zuschauern nach
welche fragen sie dann haben und da
erreicht uns über youtube 12 34 19 wird
das auch durch schmierinfektionen
schon übertragen auch immer wieder ein
thema in den letzten tagen
das liegt nicht in meiner expertise das
handy nicht gut dann fragen wir weiter
chris blight schreibt uns warum rät das
robert koch-institut allgemein von
autopsien ab mit denen man feststellen
könnte ob jemand an oder mit corona
gestorben ist eine art sie brauchen sie
ja nicht wo sie also detailliert sich
den den tod menschen anschauen sie
können sich überlegen ob sie ein test
durchführen auf ein patient eine
patientin die verstorben ist an einem
einen aktiven rico rona virus einer
infektion gelitten hat beziehungsweise
entsprechende tests im gut durchführen
das gute gewissen vorteil wenn man dann
etwas genauer wüsste ob eine corona
inspektion vielleicht eine rolle
gespielt hat eine autopsie durchzuführen
ist wesentlich aufwendiger und ich
glaube das würden wir auch von den
kapazitäten nicht moment bewältigen
können dann reden wir nochmal über die
allgemeinen maßnahmen die momentan ja
noch in kraft sind oder bzw auch über
die die es bleiben werden wenn dann eben
irgendwann schrittweise der schritt
zurück eben oder der weg zurück
eingeschlagen wird in das was wir jetzt
als normalität eigentlich kannten die
letzten jahre
welche maßnahmen glauben sie sind nach
wie vor auch in den nächsten wochen und
monaten besonders wichtig und welche
werden wahrscheinlich beibehalten werden
also ich denke dass entscheidend ist
dass wir als gesellschaft ein
bewusstsein für die situation haben dass
wir diskussionen führen bei und
maßnahmen wichtig sind und welche
maßnahmen zu welcher konsequenz
es wird auch so sein dass das ganze
natürlich nicht stabil sagt also wenn
wir jetzt im prinzip die maßnahmen
lockern er kann es dann schon auch
wieder sein dass die infektionsraten
nach oben schnellen die konsequenz für
das gesundheitssystem wieder
entsprechend sind und wird dann wieder
maßnahmen etablieren möchten damit dies
wieder verlangsamt also wir müssen uns
alle
auf einstellen dass dies noch lange so
weiter geht es im prinzip bis eben auch
um strobl medikamente zur verfügung
stehen und hier sind ja mehrere teams
weltweit und auch in deutschland daran
diese zu entwickeln und zu testen
wichtig ist wie gesagt auf eine
diskussion mit der bevölkerung sie
mitzunehmen dass sie sich einbezogen
fühlen dass sie partizipiert in dieser
diskussion weil wir es eben nur
gemeinsam schaffen für diese krise zu
bewältigen wäre denn eigentlich aus
ihrer sicht eine pflicht zum tragen von
schutzmasken auch für die normale
bevölkerung sinnvoll
also ich denke im moment ist die
schutzmasken vorwiegend medizinischen
personal gehören
wenn wir uns alle strikt an die gene
regeln und maßnahmen halten würden
würden sie wahrscheinlich nicht so viel
mehr bringen
da es aber manchmal eben schwierig ist
und man eine gewisse ja andere
vielleicht verhaltensweise dann dann
führt mag es hier und da sind zwar seien
aber professor bieler vom robert koch
institut hat er auch schon gesagt dass
man sich dann vielleicht zu sehr in
sicherheit wiegt weil diese masken der
leben mehr oder weniger vor einer
infektion schützen bzw auch das
verhindert dass man selber andere
infiziert also wenn man selber krank ist
macht ist absolut sind eine maske zu
tragen ob wir das alle kommen müssen
das kann man dann vielleicht doch etwas
detaillierter diskutieren von vielen
erwartet oder fast ersehnt werden ja
auch die antikörper tests die jetzt
demnächst dann auch in großer zahl auch
bei uns eingesetzt werden sollen
vielleicht können sie gerade noch mal
erklären warum die wichtig sind wir
haben auch eine entsprechende frage auf
youtube von fm können nicht mittels
dieser tests ja demnächst also ein
großteil eben hier in dieser form
untersucht werden ein großteil der
bevölkerung um damit eben auch weitere
erkenntnisse zu gewinnen für maßnahmen
die dann eventuell sinnvoll sind oder
für solche die es dann nicht mehr sind
das wird auf jeden fall sehr wichtig
sein werden
bisher standen ja diese pcr test zur
verfügung wurde ja aktive virus
nachgewiesen werden kann
wenn man eine infektion durch macht
entwickelter körper eine immunität und
diese immunität können sie im gut
entsprechend zu messen das heißt sie
werden in zukunft dann feststellen wer
eine infektion durchlaufen hat und ob
entsprechend uns eine immunität besteht
die dann für eine weitere infektion
wichtig ist dass man nicht mehr in wedel
infiziert wird oder eine sehr geringe
viruslast hat man muss aber auch wissen
dass zwischen der aktiven infektions
phase und der immunität ein gewisses
zeitfenster besteht so dass man eben
auch entsprechend zum richtigen
zeitpunkt testen muss die tests werden
jetzt helfe ich sein die labor bereiten
sich darauf vor dass man sehr viele
gruppen pro tag messen kann und das wird
uns auf jeden fall helfen um
entsprechend die maßnahmen der zukunft
besser beurteilen oder anders beurteilen
zu können
ich weiß es ist ein bisschen der blick
in die glaskugel aber wenn es zum
schluss noch zum schluss noch mal
sprechen über die perspektive wovon
gehen sie aus von welchem zeithorizont
wie lange wird unser leben so wie wir es
kannten noch dauerhaft also
eingeschränkt sein nachhaltig
eingeschränkt sein
und was ist vielleicht auch mit den
risikogruppen wie lange werden sich
ältere oder vor erkrankte menschen noch
darauf einstellen müssen sozial doch
relativ stark isoliert zu sein frage
verstehe sich natürlich auch ganz
natürlich jetzt auch nicht präzise
beantworten wir lernen eigentlich jeden
tag dazu schauen uns diese entwicklung
die eben auch jetzt in dem bericht
gekommen sind sehr genau an
ich denke es wird uns in eine ganze zeit
noch beschäftigen aber wir müssen eben
versuchen wir gemeinsam das zu verstehen
und gemeinsam auf die maßnahmen zu
verstehen wir müssen auch hoffnung im
prinzip kommunizieren dass man auch weiß
dass dinge guest besser werden
beziehungsweise auch andere dinge mit in
der öffentlichkeit diskutieren damit
hier eben jeder mitgenommen werden kann
genau vorhersagen sind sind wirklich
sehr schwierig in die wissenschaft alles
wüsste und sich eigentlich wäre der
vorstand keine wissenschaft mehr
insofern versuchen wir hier gemeinsam
von verschiedenen seiten der
wissenschaft von verschiedenen experten
eben die politik zu beraten dann wird
die politik dann die richtigen
entscheidungen treffen kann weil es ist
die politik die die entscheidung trifft
und nicht die wissenschaft
das wird das auch noch mal klar gestellt
haben herr professor kurt vielen dank
für dieses gespräch einiges konnten wir
nur anreißen aber ich denke trotzdem wir
haben einige interessante einblicke in
ihre sicht der dinge noch mal gewonnen
professor kurt war das von der berliner
charité vielen dank einen schönen abend
an sie und euch natürlich auch lieben
dank liebe zuschauer vielen dank auch
für eure fragen das war es von uns an
dieser stelle wir wünschen euch einen
schönen abend und bis demnächst
[Musik]
so und wenn euch dieser streamen
gefallen hat dann schlagen wir euch
folgendes vor ihr guckt euch entweder
das hier noch mal an das ist die korona
sprechstunde mit harald lesch da geht es
auch um die zukunft nach gronau oder ihr
guckt hier nochmal rein da erzählt uns
eine krankenschwester was momentan
wirklich gebraucht wird hier an dieser
stelle könnt ihr euch anschauen was es
alles für themen gibt in unserer corona
sprechstunde beziehungsweise mit wem wir
da alles gesprochen haben und vergesst
nicht eure zdf heute app zu
aktualisieren die ist nämlich komplett
überarbeitet worden